When you think of a polar bear,
you might think white, cold,
cute, fuzzy, huggable.
Or maybe you feel a bit sad,
imagining a polar bear floating away
on a melting ice floe.
Either way, there's
a good chance that for you,
polar bears are a distant reality.
But think of those living
and working in the Arctic.
For them, melting ice doesn't mean
polar bears floating away.
It means the bears getting stuck on land
and more desperate for food.
For them, polar bears
can be a daily reality.
And whether this reality
feels safe or scary
depends on how well prepared people are
to coexist with the world's largest
four-legged predator.
After working and living off and on
with polar bears for over 12 years,
I know coexisting with them
can be a challenge,
and it will only get more challenging
as climate change forces our species
to increasingly overlap
in the coming decades.
With my organization,
Polar Bears International,
I'm focused on conserving wild polar bears
while respecting and assisting those
who share their coastlines
with this carnivore.
To understand how to best coexist
with polar bears,
we first need to understand them.
And I think one
of the best places to start
is with one of the most common
questions I get asked,
which is, "How are they actually doing?"
It's a great question.
It's simple, but the answer
has some nuance
and can depend on where
we're looking in time and space.
If we could pause time
and stop all the impacts
we're having on the planet,
then sure, right now
the species would be okay.
We still have about 25,000 polar bears
spread across the Arctic,
split into 19 different populations
in Canada, Russia, Norway,
Greenland and Alaska.
But obviously, we can't pause time.
The world is warming
and the Arctic is warming
faster than anywhere.
If we did nothing
to change our current path,
we could lose most
of the world's polar bears
by the end of the century
due to habitat loss.
Populations are experiencing changes
at different rates
depending on where they are,
but ultimately all will be impacted
unless we collectively switch
to cleaner energies.
So we're racing time to tackle
climate change in the long term
and in the short term,
trying to keep as many polar bears
in the wild as possible.
But in the short term,
one of the biggest hurdles
these charismatic megafauna face is us.
Polar bears use the frozen
ocean for traveling,
mating and hunting their main prey: seals.
Specifically, high-calorie seal blubber.
Polar bears can't outswim seals,
so they use the sea ice to sneak up
on unsuspecting prey.
Polar bears need sea ice
for sustenance and survival, period.
So what happens when ice bears
start losing their ice?
They get stuck on land
and they get hungry.
Polar bears want and need blubber,
but they're still bears,
so they will follow their noses
to fill their tummies,
whatever that takes.
But it takes a lot.
Just one polar bear needs a lot of seals,
and just one seal is equal
to about 74 snow geese
or 216 snow goose eggs --
it's a big omelet --
or three million crowberries.
This amount of food
doesn't exist on the tundra
in quantities great enough
to sustain a population
of blubber-hunting ice bears.
So when polar bears can't find
good food to eat,
just like people,
they'll fill up on junk food.
And for polar bears,
junk food is human food.
And for a hungry bear,
the best late-night fast food takeout
can be their northern
neighborhood's trash.
But we have a saying in conservation:
a fed bear is a dead bear,
and this has major implications
for coexistence.
Many people work and live
across the north,
and some Indigenous cultures
have centuries-old,
deep knowledge of polar bears.
But as the world is warming
and bears are spending more time on land,
more people are moving north
and also spending more time on the land
and bringing with them
more food and more garbage.
And they might not be so bear aware.
This is a rising safety concern for humans
who are always the number-one priority.
It's also a concern for the bears
because when a polar bear has a negative
encounter with a human,
it risks being taken out
of the population in a defense kill,
which is the legal killing of an animal
to defend life or property.
Now here, I should also mention
that in parts of the range,
polar bears are harvested
under a quota system
informed by science
and Indigenous knowledge.
If I don't mention it,
people can think I'm hiding it,
and when I do, they can be surprised
that I'm not opposed.
It is incredibly important
that we protect the rights
of Indigenous peoples
to practice their traditions.
And right now that practice is not
a significant threat to the species.
Where we could see
population-level impacts
is through climate change,
or if defense kills,
which count toward quotas,
defense kills start rising
above the relatively low quotas.
That's when I worry.
But people can't worry about conservation
when their lives are at risk.
So we need to help limit
negative polar bear encounters
and support people
in protecting themselves
with whatever tools work best for them.
And to help with that, we can
provide tools that are non-lethal.
Luckily, non-lethal tools are available
and more are being developed,
particularly in Canada,
which is home to two thirds
of the world's polar bears.
And one of the best
testing grounds for tools
is in the self-proclaimed
polar bear capital of the world,
Churchill, Manitoba.
Churchill is home to the western
Hudson Bay population,
some of the best-studied and most-southern
polar bears in the world.
In this region,
the ice-free season is lengthening,
meaning these bears are on land longer
and have less access to calories
compared to their grandparents.
This does not mean all the bears
are starving to death.
It means the females are having
a harder time having cubs,
the cubs are having
a harder time becoming adults
and some bears have just moved elsewhere
in search of better conditions.
As a result, this population has declined
from about 1,200 bears in the 1980s,
to just over 600 today, almost 50 percent.
Churchill is also home
to about 900 people,
but grows by thousands
during tourist season.
And visitors do sometimes ask me,
"Do polar bears really come into town
or is this some tourism ploy?"
Oh yeah, they come into town.
So this is from last fall,
which is in bear season,
October, November in Churchill,
and the local woman had gone out through
a living room about 4 am
and watched this through her window.
And no doubt she called
the Polar Bear Alert hotline right after,
which is a real thing.
But you can tell how big they are,
curious and pretty rude.
(Laughter)
So polar bears are an economic
keystone in Churchill,
driving tourism and creating jobs.
It's important Churchill protects
them and their people,
which they do through a wide
variety of efforts.
But one of the most interesting
and effective is their waste management.
Unsurprisingly, Churchill's garbage
dump used to be outdoors,
which was fine until it became
a popular polar bear buffet.
So this is a problem
for the bear's health,
but also because when they're
on their way to the snack bar,
they risk bumping into people.
Polar bears are no more likely
to actively hunt
and kill people than black bears,
But they are more likely
to attack near towns,
especially when food is nearby.
So Churchill did the smart thing,
and they've just moved
their garbage dump indoors.
Now the bears can't even get to it.
They also installed residential
bear resistant bins,
so no polar bear with late night munchies
in this town gets any rotten food rewards.
Churchill continues to evolve
their waste management
because it's key in coexistence.
But not everywhere can do
what Churchill's done.
So we need more options.
Polar Bears International is working
on innovative technologies
that could help provide longer lead times
between when polar bears and people meet
or prevent them from meeting altogether.
Just one example, GPS tracking.
It can tell us where, when
and why polar bears move.
It's critical data,
but we've only successfully
collared adult females.
Adult males have these like pylon heads
with necks thicker than their skulls,
and they just pull collars right off.
And then the subadults are still growing.
And this is really too bad
because the subadults, or the teenagers,
often cause the most trouble,
big surprise.
(Laughter)
So we've started working with 3M,
the sticky stuff company
that makes Post-it notes,
and they're helping us figure out
how to stick a tracker to any bear's fur.
These "burr on fur" tags
could be a conservation game changer,
letting us temporarily tag any bear
that comes too close to a community.
And upon relocation,
we can track that bear
and intercept it before it gets too close.
This could help reduce dumpster diving
and reduce negative human-bear encounters,
keeping both species safer.
We also hope the tags
could be used on other species
that maybe need some support
staying away from us humans.
So there's different coexistence
tools being worked on
for different needs across the north,
but we can't talk about conservation
without mentioning one of the most
important tools of all -- education.
If you are going into bear country,
polar or otherwise, please get bear aware.
Stay together, secure your snacks
and carry a deterrent like flares
or bangers or bear spray.
Bear spray works
even in the cold and the wind.
But finally, the number one most important
coexistence tool we have
is our willingness to cut carbon emissions
and stop trapping so much heat
in our atmosphere.
But on that note, I have some optimism.
Sea ice.
It's very responsive
to atmospheric temperatures.
We can keep this habitat in the Arctic,
but it will mean drastically
reducing our emissions
and eventually getting them to zero.
Polar bears are fat, white,
hairy canaries in the coal mine,
warning us to act now.
The faster we switch to cleaner energies,
the better we can protect future
generations of polar bears and people.
I'd be lying if I said I wasn't worried,
but action is the best
antidote to anxiety.
And I'm working to ensure climate change
doesn't separate our species for good.
But until then, it's bringing
us too close together.
Coexistence is the only option.
Let's make it safe for all.
Thank you.
(Applause)